[Music]
straight ahead
all lawn crime daily survivors of the
1921 tulsa race massacre
testify on the 100-year anniversary of
the violence that killed dozens of black
americans
and caused millions of dollars in damage
i have waited so long for justice
defense attorneys for an iowa farm
worker accused of murdering a college
student
press the former officer who says
christian vegena rivera
confessed to killing mollie tibbetts you
interviewed my client for
11 hours correct yes accused kenosha
shooter kyle reitenhaus
appears in court in person for the first
time as attorneys prepare
for trial and in the robert durst trial
the former medical examiner
testifies victim susan berman may have
never seen her killer coming
she was on her knees and cleaning up the
dog
mess at the time she was shot that is a
possibility
certainly law and crime daily covering
court cases from coast to coast
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin
survivors of the tulsa race massacre are
sharing their eyewitness accounts on the
capitol
hill as they pursue a lawsuit calling
the government responsible
two weeks ago i celebrated my 107th
birthday for viola ford fletcher this
year's birthday is especially important
i'm here seeking justice and i'm asking
my country to acknowledge what happened
in tulsa in 1921. in 1921 fletcher was
just seven years old
living in the greenwood district of
tulsa oklahoma i felt safe
i had everything a child could need i
had a bright future ahead with me
greenwood was thriving and was even
known as black wall street
but on may 31st fletcher's parents woke
her and her five siblings up
in the middle of the night and said they
had to leave immediately
i will never forget the violence of the
white mob
when we left our home i still see black
men
sin being shot black bodies lying in the
street
i still smell smoke and sea fire
i still see black businesses being
burned
i hear the screams i have lived through
damascus
every day fletcher is one of three tulsa
massacre survivors to testify
before congress on the centennial
anniversary of the massacre
a white mob killed as many as 300 people
left nearly 10 000 homeless
and burned 23 churches because of the
massacre
my family was driven out of our homes
we were left with nothing hugh's van
ellis fletcher's younger brother
is best known as uncle redd he's now a
hundred years
old he says he served in world war ii
but returned
only to be met with discrimination we
aren't just
black and like pictures
on a screen we all flex
and blood i was there when
it happened i'm still here
the riots were sparked when a black man
was accused of sexually assaulting a
white woman
a rumor spread he was to be lynched and
a mob of hundreds of white men
many deputized and armed gathered
outside the courthouse
75 black men gathered to protect the man
and were traced into greenwood
violence erupted a grand jury blamed the
black men and local authorities placed
thousands of black residents
in internment camps officials later
concluded the man likely tripped over
the woman's foot
i have waited so long for justice leslie
beninfield randall
now 106 says she didn't think she would
make it out of the attacks alive
it was like a war white men with guns
came and destroyed my community
we couldn't understand why in 2005 the
u.s supreme court
declined to hear a case brought by
survivors federal appeal judges ruled
they waited too long to file their
lawsuit now
beninfield randall is the lead plaintiff
in a suit filed in tulsa county district
court
seeking reparations from the city and
other government entities
it seems like justice
in america is always so slow
are not possible for black people
please give me my family
and my community some justice the
survivors contend the local government
uses their names
without their consent to raise tens of
millions of dollars
while they continue to live in poverty
no one cared about us for almost 100
years
we in our history have been forgotten
washed away this congress must recognize
us
i have been blessed with a long life
and have seen the best and the worst of
this country
i think about the terror horror
inflicted upon black people in this
country every day
i have lived through damascus every day
a country may forget this history but i
cannot
i will not and other survivors do not
joining us today is co-founder and
executive director of partners for
justice emily galvin almanza
and terry austin emily how would you
characterize i guess the almost
100-year response against the lawsuit of
these survivors and the harm they
described does it surprise you
100-year non-response i mean let's think
about it this way
we're my my area of work specializes in
stabilizing people who are
interfacing between poverty and the
criminal legal system so i think a lot
about how much
wealth stability and safety influence
political power political voice
advancement people's futures the tulsa
massacre didn't just result in a loss of
life it erased
the livelihoods the wealth the stability
of tens of thousands of people
when you look a hundred years later at
how
nothing was done to make that right to
help people recover
um how in fact the damage was compounded
by like subsequent zoning changes
designed to prevent black families from
getting their homes back to prevent them
from rebuilding to prevent them from
finding stability this is not uh the act
of
you know some bad people and tell us a
100 years ago this is a systemic
governmental policy choice that
undermined the futures of tens of
thousands of people and the fact that
nothing has been done about it and that
i grew up
about 500 miles away from tulsa i never
learned about this in school
that it is not taught it is not talked
about it is a hundred year erasure
and the least that could be done now is
a form of reparations to make
it right agree now terry do you think
the words of the survivors at this
congressional hearing
will help either this change that
emily's talking about or at the very
least their civil case
well you know it's going to help because
it puts names and faces
together and people will be able to
relate to that and the lawsuit involves
claims against the city of tulsa the
state of oklahoma
and also the police department and the
reason is because they
are owed reparations they were
responsible there are some statute of
limitations problems
but there are new evidence that they
want to present now
saying that this creation of a
commission will really
bring the case back so hopefully they
won't have that issue
and they'll be able to bring the suit
you have some of the best attorneys
helping including charles ogitry the
harvard law school professor so
hopefully they'll prevail
yeah and i understand the statute of
limitations argument but is anyone
really believing that in the 30s
the 40s the 50s or the 60s that this
would have had a legitimate claim in any
court in this country
i don't think so so i think now is
probably the right time for this to go
forward
thank you both still ahead on law and
crime daily the accused kenosha shooter
appears in person in a wisconsin
courtroom for the first time
but first the police interrogation of
mollie tibbetts accused murderer
and why the jury in the christian benejo
rivera trial
won't get to see all of his alleged
confession next
[Music]
welcome back the former police officer
who got a confession in the molly
tibbetts murder
tells the jury what christian boneja
rivera told her
law and crimes angenette levy is in
davenport iowa with a riveting testimony
pamela romero used to be a police
officer with iowa city
she was brought in to interview
christian bahina rivera because she's a
native spanish speaker
just like him mr rivera told me that he
saw her three times he saw her
first turn around came back
he stated that she even waved at him and
smiled
pamela romero said that christian bahina
rivera claimed he was driving around
brooklyn to get a vacuum cleaner from
his uncle's home on july 18
2018 and saw a woman running
did he ever use any other term other
than attractive
to describe the runner
that he saw he stated at one point that
he thought that she was hot
romero said eventually bahina rivera led
them to a corn field where he said he
jogged behind mollie tibbetts
and approached her rivera said that she
made the attempt
to use the cell phone later telling me
that
she told him that she was going to call
the police
and what was the defendant's reaction to
molly tibbetts threat to call the police
mr rivera said that he got angry
then romera said behena rivera said
molly tibbetts slapped him
he stated that usually when he became
becomes angry
or when he gets mad he blocks out so the
next
thing that he told me was that um he
remember
him driving and looking down into
his legs and finding the earbuds that
belong
to molly and that is when he remembered
that he had a molly in the back of his
vehicle in the trunk
the defense played a portion of the
11-hour interview that showed begina
rivera sitting alone eating a sandwich
and drinking a soda
it was one of the several breaks police
say they gave bahana rivera
but his lawyers suggest he was tired and
made a false confession
it's important for you to get a good
confession
is that right that is the goal of the
interview
to get the truth out of that now the
blackout
that was suggested here that was your
suggestion to mr rivera that he might
have some sort of a condition
isn't that right that is i do not recall
that
why would you tell my client that he's
not telling the truth
again at the beginning of the interview
he was stating that he was not aware of
knowing her
until we show him the pictures of the
black
malibu that he admitted that it was his
on re cross
romero said bahina rivera did not have
trouble understanding her questions
were you pleasant with the
defendant yes the prosecution is
claiming that the defense
opened the door to show portions of
bahina rivera's interview that had been
suppressed because romero didn't read
his miranda rights to him properly
at the beginning of the interview the
judge disagreed though and said that
could change
depending on what the defense presents
in its case in chief
for law and crime daily in davenport
iowa i'm angenette levy
back with us as executive director of
partners for justice
emily galvin almanza and terry austin
terry the prosecution obviously wants
vegeta rivera's excluded statements in
do you agree with the judge's ruling to
not let them in now
you know i do think the defense opened
the door there i think the judge could
have ruled but he's being very careful
he wants no grounds for appeal here
and if in fact the miranda rights were
not read properly in the beginning
then there would be a problem with using
the actual admission
by the defendant but we have ms rivera
who is
on the stand and she's testifying she
was there she's testifying about
what she was told she made it very clear
that the defendant told her where the
body was and
led the police to the scene and the
cornfields
and she made it very clear that no one
else provided that information
so the fact of the matter has gotten in
even though we don't see it
coming literally from rivera's own mouth
during the admission emily how difficult
is arguing false confession in general
if not just this case
it's difficult but it's not impossible
and if people knew more about the
methods that police use to obtain a
confession it probably would be a lot
easier
a police interrogation isn't just a
person questioning another person it's
actually
a psychiatrically informed method of
extracting a confession from a person
that means that the way in which it's
carried out is designed to get a person
to say they did it whether they did it
or not
guilt or innocence is irrelevant in a
police
interrogation here we have an 11-hour
interrogation following what defense
says was a 12-hour work shift
i mean anybody would be exhausted and as
we all know exhaustion makes a person
more susceptible to false confession
in an interrogation context yeah
understanding language the length of the
interrogation
whether food was given and also what
we've heard of
in this network at least the read
technique reid is a technique that
many officers still use even though most
science says it's not the greatest for
getting out
true confessions coming up on law and
crime daily
friends of a woman missing since the 80s
testify in court against robert durst
plus kyle rinhaus makes his first
in-person appearance in a wisconsin
courtroom
everything you need to know about the
accused sugars trial after the break
we're back accused kenosha shooter kyle
renton house made his first in-person
appearance in a wisconsin courtroom on
friday
the eight-year-old is charged with
shooting and killing joseph rosenbaum
and anthony hoover
as well as winning gage grosskovitz the
defense attorneys say the then 17 year
old was acting in self-defense
citing a video showing their client
getting hit in the head with a
skateboard before he fired the fatal
bullets
rinhaus is currently out on two million
dollars bail his trial is set to begin
november 1st
but for this hearing there was one
pressing issue the prosecution
wanted to take note of jury
questionnaires
question that i have is with regard to
jury questionnaires i think
the parties are in agreement that this
is a case where we will need jury
questionnaires
that's going to be a process that's
going to take some time to draft them up
for the parties and the court to review
them and
come to some agreement on them and then
of course in advance of trial
we're going to need to build in time for
those to be sent out
and returned by the jurors and time for
the parties
to be able to analyze them before jury
selection
we have picked another status date of
july 28th
at 2 pm we picked that off the record
with your clerk
and i think that we can perhaps
narrow down the jury questionnaire
timing at that point i don't think we
necessarily need to pick a deadline
right now
but i do think that's something we need
to keep in the back of our mind
now let's bring back emily galvin
almanza emily emily
rittenhouse's case has the country
divided hero to some deadly menace to
others how important is jury selection
in a case like this for either side
jury selection is always everything in a
case um
you're choosing the people who are going
to make the ultimate decision about the
fate of your client
and you have the opportunity ideally to
learn a great deal about those people
often things that would surprise you so
in this case we've got people who are
very politically divided on the issue of
the role of cal rittenhouse
yet some people who may be most um
repulsed by his views
might also be the people most
sympathetic to a young person
seeking mercy from a jury so it could be
a deeply
significant yet challenging process to
select a jury yeah that questionnaire is
going to be very interesting to see how
it
ends up of course we'll pull it apart
and when we get it thanks for the input
emily
when we come back the trial of robert
durst did susan berman see her killer
before she was shot
the medical examiner's answer to that
pressing question on the other side of
this break
welcome back we're taking a closer look
at the robert durst trial
out of california the real estate air is
accused of murdering his longtime friend
susan berman in december of 2000.
prosecutors say durst shot berman in the
back of the head
execution style because she had
information about durst involvement
in the disappearance of his first wife
kathy in 1982.
on cross-examination the defense asked
the los angeles county medical examiner
if berman would have seen her killer
coming
apparently there was an effort to clean
up
the dog pooping inside but
i don't know if that's actually true but
that's a possibility sure
and i believe you've testified before
and i think you did today
that there's a possibility that she was
on her knees
at the time she was shot that is a
possibility sure
is this consistent with the evidence
that she was on her knees and
cleaning up the dog mess
at the time she was shot that is a
possibility certainly
and certainly uh because of the way the
bullet entered her head from the back
she did not see
it coming that would be my supposition
that would be my theory correct
and it's just as reasonable that she
didn't know that there was someone
that was about to shoot her that is a
possibility sure
prosecutors say berman called the dean
of kathy's med school pretending to be
kathy to say she wouldn't be coming in
for rotations
one of kathy's classmates testified that
was unusual to call
the dean an impossible domestic violence
the biggest image i have of her is the
dark sunglasses
in the
[Music]
cafeteria that was my biggest memory
and when you say the dark glasses does
that include the black eye
as well yes would you expect in your
experience knowing kathy that she would
have
referred to her condition rather than
saying i have a gastrointestinal issue
or i'm ill
of literally describing to an older man
in a position of authority
i've got diarrhea cramps and a headache
that's
repetitious um
i'm not sure you were aware then that
kathy had uh
dropped out of a couple of her rotations
i was not aware of that
did you check to see if she was doing
okay or not
i did not i looked at my own grades
emily the defense got out this theory
that uh berman may have been doing
something other than being on the ground
and shot from behind
that she could have been cleaning up dog
poop strong argument or
something else you know i think it's
actually really strange for a medical
examiner to be
putting forth suppositions about who
trusted whom because remember the
prosecution theory isn't just
her position it's that her position
indicated
that her killer had a position of trust
with her
which is very hard to determine from a
person's body angle right like there's a
million reasons why a person could be
down picking something up off the ground
so
very rarely a person the position of a
wound is
dispositive in a case here i don't think
it is right now terry
kathy's classmate gave us a lot of
background information
but how is the prosecution tying that
into durst is a murderer
you know i think what we were trying to
get out of this witness
is the fact that frankly we know that
durst is a close friend of kathy
uh and of susan rather and
that uh you know durst is violent that
for many years you know she was coming
to class and her classmates saw her
and she saw that she did have some
bruises at some
point in time and so the implication
there
is that perhaps robert durst was
responsible for these bruises and making
him
seem as though he is someone who could
have
harmed his wife and killed her and you
know that is exactly what the
prosecution is trying to show here
absolutely elon crime has the only
cameras in the robert durst trial make
sure to check it out
thanks for joining us we'll see you next
time as we discuss justice in america
[Music]
[Music]
you